there were 400 people in the building
when the car bomb exploded according to
eyewitnesses a suicide bomber rammed the
vehicle through two sets of gates then
plowed into the main reception this was
supposed to be a secure compound but the
suicide bomber managed to break through
to carry out one of the most devastating
attacks against the UN in the last
decade this was an assault on those who
devote their lives to helping others we
condemned this a terrible act utterly we
do not yet have criticized the casualty
figures but they are likely to be
considerable what number of people are
dead many more are wounded the Islamist
group Boko Haram are the most likely
architects of all this they are fighting
for the introduction of Sharia law and
are even thought to be pursuing new
links with al-qaeda in North Africa and
Al Shabaab in Somalia
Boko Haram have been behind a wave of
attacks against government institutions
including a car bombing of Nigeria's
police headquarters in June in which two
people died the UN suffered a
devastating attack on its compound in
Baghdad in 2003 in which more than 20
people died for that al Qaeda claimed
responsibility then and now the UN will
be urgently reassessing its operations
in Africa recently inaugurated president
of nigeria Goodluck Jonathan has
condemned the suicide bombing as
despicable and has put security forces
across the capital on high alert